[Música]
y comenzábamos revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez más deudor Rosa Buenos días
Buenos días media Clara y abrimos esta
sección hablando del reporte que hizo el
periódico británico de Guardian porque
el Ministerio del interior admite que
200 menores de edad solicitantes de
asilo están desaparecidos Qué pasó con
ellos efectivamente esto en Reino Unido
María Clara y es que a raíz de una
pregunta en la cámara de los lores la
cámara alta del Reino Unido expresada
por el partido liberal un representante
del Ministerio del interior del Reino
Unido tuvo que admitir que efectivamente
como bien decías hay 200 menores
solicitantes de asilo cuyo paradero es
desconocido para las autoridades a pesar
de que estaban temporalmente pues siendo
hospedados en hoteles gestionados por
las autoridades británicas bien en este
caso esta admisión este reconocimiento
por parte de un político británico llega
a raíz como bien decías de la
investigación de Mark Thousand que hace
unos días de hecho el pasado sábado
publicaba que menores solicitantes de
asilo fueron secuestrados A las afueras
de hoteles gestionados por el Ministerio
de interior británico en Brighton según
información filtrada por una trabajador
en condición de anonimato de ese hotel
bien el Ministerio del interior Cómo se
defiende diciendo que el gobierno no
puede retener a estos menores de dentro
de los hoteles que tienen derecho a
salir a las calles no y que
supuestamente estarían siendo
secuestrados en las inmediaciones de las
instalaciones por otro lado
organizaciones de defensa de los
derechos humanos y particularmente de
los menores denuncian El desprecio de
las autoridades británicas a sus
ofrecimientos de ayuda para gestionar
estos hoteles señalan que es injustifica
injustificable
desentenderse de menores en situación de
tanta vulnerabilidad de Guardian señala
quizás los criminales les que si no van
con ellos el gobierno los mandará a
Ruanda no recordemos este tema de las
deportaciones a este tercer país
africano mientras que la policía
advierte al gobierno repetidamente no de
este peligro De hecho no es una cuestión
nueva ya se habló en octubre sin embargo
va volviéndose
continúa saliendo la luz y cada vez hay
más presión sobre las autoridades del
Reino Unido bueno Y como usted lo dice
no
es un basando en
Reino Unido las grandes diferencias es
que el tema saltó a los medios
internacionales qué están diciendo
empecemos a por la bbc que da una
fotografía más amplia sobre las cifras
no de este tema del que estamos hablando
y Es que desde 2021 habrían llegado
4.600 menores solicitantes de asilo al
Reino Unido de los cuales
440 habrían desaparecido y unos 200
habrían nacido localizados finalmente
por las autoridades británicas que
estiman a que los que no pueden ser
localizados en algunos casos Podrían
haber regresado a sus hogares pero en
muchos otros casos posiblemente han
caído en redes de trata de personas por
otro lado María Clara solo para terminar
muy rápidamente enviar la radio pública
estadounidense señala que bien es
denunciable esta situación teniendo en
cuenta que ya estos a menores han pasado
por situaciones de mucho peligro
arriesgado su vida para poder llegar al
reino y siguen señala precisamente los
orígenes de la mayoría de estos menores
que vendrían en su mayoría de Albania
pero también de Afganistán Egipto India
Vietnam Pakistán y Turquía y lo propongo
que nos quedemos con otro medio
estadounidense porque en el New York
Times Peter Baker está escribiendo que
la gestión que ha hecho el presidente
Joe biden sobre los documentos
clasificados que se han encontrado en su
residencia complica el caso del
exmandatario Donald Trump Por qué bien
un poco la tesis no desea analista
político es que si bien los casos del
supuesto mal manejo de documentos
recordemos que en las residencias
privadas de ambos presidentes se han
encontrado gobiernos presidenciales
gobiernos hay documentos gubernamentales
Perdón los casos difieren sin embargo de
Cara a la opinión pública el hecho de
que biden esté implicado no en un caso
parecido impide a los demócratas
utilizar el caso de Trump en una
eventual campaña
electoral en 2024 En qué concurriera no
el expresidente Donald Trump bien
desarrollamos Un poco este artículo como
decíamos el número de documentos
encontrados en caso de Trump en caso de
biden es muy distinto como fueron
encontrados también la cooperación de
ambos mandatarios con las autoridades
también vista radicalmente Pero dice
Peter Baker sin embargo son
suficientemente parecidos para que en la
práctica los demócratas les resulte
difícil usar el tema políticamente
contra el expresidente Donald Trump no
el tema como decíamos este mal manejo de
documentos gubernamentales dice quizás a
nivel judicial queden nada pero biden lo
tiene complicado en el tribunal de la
opinión pública y cerramos con una
encuesta de ABC news con ipsos en que
encontró que el 70% de las personas a
las que se le preguntó consideran que
Trump actuó mal pero no tan lejos del
64% que consideran que biden también
actuó mal un 43% considera que el caso
de Trump es más grave un 20 ciento
considera que el caso de biden es más
grave y un 30% de los consideró
Igualmente graves acaba este artículo
diciendo que es sin embargo es un
maestro un campeón de la manipulación no
finalmente del debate público y de
enturbiar las aguas a su favor y un caso
que ahora está salpicando también al
vicepresidente al antiguo vicepresidente
Mike pence Gracias Rosa por esta revista
de prensa a ti María Clara Hasta mañana
hasta mañana